a line goes through the following points
and the equation of that line is written
in y equals MX plus B form also known as
slope-intercept form what is the
equation of the line so the first thing
we want to think about what is the slope
of this line what is M here so what is
our change in Y for given change in X so
this is an interesting example here and
I encourage you to pause the video and
try it out yourself because no matter
how much we change X Y is not changing Y
is a constant - so your change in Y
between any two points is going to be
zero it doesn't matter what your change
in X is your change in X could be 1 your
change in X could be four your change in
Y is always zero so Y is not changing as
you change X so your slope for this for
this relationship is actually zero Y is
equal to zero X + and then you could you
could just realize that this is this the
equation of this is just that Y is
always equal to 2 so it's zero X + 2
which is the same thing as Y is equal to
2 you could substitute back in you could
say ok well Y is equal to zero X plus B
that means that Y is equal to B well Y
is always equal to 2 no matter what pick
what no matter what thing do pick so B
is equal to 2 so either way you this
just boils down to Y is equal to 0 X
plus 2 or Y is just equal to 2 let's do
another one of these maybe one where the
Y is actually changing so here the Y is
clearly the Y is actually changing so
let me copy and paste this so let me
copy and paste this one put it on my
scratch pad and we could work it out so
let's stick it right over here and then
we are told we are told a line goes
through the file ok so the same thing
the line goes through these points
what's the equation of the line so the
main idea here is you only need two
points for an equation of line they've
given us more than necessary so I'd like
to pick the two points that make things
a little bit simpler so I'll pick the
point 4 2 + 7 0 I just picked those two
points because they have nice clean
numbers associated with it
so what is our change in X here so our
change in X here if we go from four to
seven our chin X is equal to three
change in X is equal to three and what's
our change in Y here so we went up from
four to seven we increased by three our
Y decreased by two change in Y is equal
to negative two so our slope which is
equal to change in Y over change in X is
equal to negative two thirds and if you
wanted to relate that to the formulas
that you normally see for slope you're
just looking at your end point so this
is y2 minus y1 which is negative 2 over
x2 minus x1 which is 7 minus 4 but that
just boils down to negative 2/3 and it's
and so our equation is going to be Y is
equal to negative 2/3 X plus B so let's
substitute one of these points in here
to figure out what our B must be and
once again I like let's see I want to
figure out something where this is going
to become nice and clean but this isn't
going to be clean really clean for any
of these numbers right over here if this
if we had a 3 for X or 6 for X or a 0
for X then things would work out nicely
but they don't give us any of those so
let's just try let's just try the 7 and
this is 0 so when X is equal to 0 sorry
when X is equal to 7 Y is equal to 0 so
when X is equal to 7 I'll just do the
same color Y is equal to 0 so 0 is equal
to negative 2/3 times 7 plus B or 0 is
equal to negative 14 over 3 3 plus B add
14 over 3 to both sides you get 14 over
3 is equal to B so this is going to be y
is equal to negative let me go back to
the other screen so it's y is equal to
negative 2/3 X plus 14 over 3 so let me
do that so Y is equal to Y is equal to
negative 2/3 X negative 2/3 X plus 14
over 3 14 over 3 let's check our answer
we got it right